are the treatment of American Indians  today by the film industry  excuse me  this was one of the most famous moments  in the history of the Oscars apparently  John Wayne had to be restrained from  going up and just like throwing this  woman off the stage but it's a very very  famous moment it's one really kind of  the beginning of the politicizing of the  Oscars and making it all about this  partisan nonsense well anyway  it was 40 50 years later now it turns  out that that Apache lady Sachin  littlefeather does not have one drop of  Apache blood in her her biological  sisters Rosalind Cruz and Trudy Orlandi  uh say that little feather is not Native  American at all it's a lie my father was  who he was his family came from Mexico  and my dad was born in Oxnard  this is not Native American at all